[Musique]
à 44 ans georges plaque tout échange de
vie pour s'offrir un blouson en daim ce
pitch improbable c'est celui du nouveau
long métrage signé quentin dupieux le
dain au casting adèle haenel et jean
dujardin qui plonge à bras ouverts dans
l'univers absurde du cinéaste chicza a
rencontré l'homme qui porte le dain
comme personne et son réalisateur a
choisi d'axer pas d'endettement banal je
vais confiance ou par jean desjardins
quentin dupieux bonjour merci cela alors
vous présenter le d'un genre je
m'adresse à vous en premier
tourné avec quentin dupieux c'était une
envie pour vous de sortir des sentiers
battus pas du tout c'était cette annonce
était enfin si jamais comme ça que ça se
déclenche le fêter qui m'a appelé on
s'est rencontré au bout de huit heures
ou 10 heures on s'est vus osaka film a
parlé très rapidement de ce truc ça m'a
plu immédiatement je lui ai répondu je
pense dans la foulée et on parlait pas
de sentiers battus donc parler très
antipathique j'ai en fait la même
manière que vous savez comme quand vous
partez en vacances des fois vous avez
envie de montagne des fois vous avez une
merde et fois aux envies de j'aime avoir
des sensations mais c'est surtout c'est
que j'aime pas m'ennuyer est vraiment
pas au cinéma parce que j'aime trop ça
en fait j'aime trop le jem trop
l'excitation d'un tournage le l'avant le
pendant et après la fabrication de
l'objet
l' aventure commune ce que je vais
ressentir comment elle est née cette
histoire de vous le dire assez compliqué
non mais j'ai pris l'habitude je ne
réponds jamais à cette question
alors si quand même on peut lire que
inspiré de vos rêves que dans un demi
sommeil de raconter tout ça mais on
devrait les idées elles sont un peu
partout et ça vient comme ça et c'est
vrai que j'ai au départ j'ai écrit un
film qui était plus grotesque il y avait
une envie de films grotesque c'est un
truc que j'ai écrit en anglais
et puis en fait le projet il voit là il
restait un peu comme ça dans mon
ordinateur et puis quand je leur ai
écrit en français
c'est devenu un film un peu plus profond
et un peu plus voilà cette idée de
blouson en daim elle était là depuis le
début
et puis en fait non en fait on s'est
aussi rendu compte que thébaux est que
ce blouson quoi c'est le style de
malades de brive on lit jamais un nom
mais il est au delà du ridicule de
broadway il est même plus ridicule d'un
certain buzz sans dévoiler le la suite
du film il ya quand même un style qui
évolue à oui voilà un petit foule d'un
mec qui s'annonce m'en faut être
cohérent
c'est un mec qui est quand même en fin
de vie on peut le dire ouais c'est quoi
votre regard sur ce sommet il a passé la
ligne de crête on va dire voilà qui
n'est plus en chute il est déjà tombé je
pense on récupère là et comme quand vous
décidez dans votre vie bon il ya des
plusieurs façons d'en finir où on finit
avec un flingue dans la bouche ou
on se défenestre où on prend un
de vos ondes et on s'isole et on se
raconte des choses
en fait c'est moi j'aime bien dire que
c'est pas une descente aux enfers en
fait il part de l'enfer d'une vie
ennuyeuse peut-être servette il a une
belle courbe et à la liberté est bon il
devient un truc moi pas de révéler
effectivement mais devient quelque chose
c'est beau et puis voilà habitat vous
êtes en train de parler de mon blouson
non non non ok pardon pourquoi on part
est tombée au bon c'est parce qu'en fait
on m'en parle tout le temps quoi il faut
des gens qui m'arrêtent dans la rue je
suis habitué à ce que ça ça attire les
regards pour sa part dont moi j'étais
vraiment moi je crois que j'ai fait
quand on fait beaucoup
moi je crois que je suis un espèce d un
prolongement de quentin je pense que
secrètement il rêvait de ce blouson et
la barge et la barbe comme quand on l'y
voit là il ya de ça quatre histoires en
fait vous pouvez le dire alors c'est
vrai
même ma femme me l'a dit un oui mais tu
mets tu parles comme quentin dans le
style de malades tout ça mais moi je
dérange dit mais ça but c'est
quentin qui dit ça bute en vrai j'ai
lorgner sur une version bon temps au
soleil ne dis pas tu sais pas si c'est
vrai mais c'était pendant l'écriture du
sim pour convier le sait pas c'est pas
une maladie d'avant c'était un truc
pendant l'écriture du film j'ai lorgner
sur une veste très très cher vraiment
très cher et le mannequin là qu'il a
présentée avec un style de malade et je
mange de projeter je faisais moi je fais
être ridicule c'était certain ça ne
m'allait pas il ya plein de trucs qu'on
achète et qu'on ne met pas qu'on veut
posséder oui cet attaché au matériel
déjà tous les noms moi non mais il ya
des trucs que je veux par exemple les
bottes dans le film c'est les miennes
quoi dit la vraie histoire
il avait ses bottes il n'a jamais osé
les portes et parce qu'elle était moche
c'est des canards à s'en aller marquer
j'adore les camarguaise parce que ça
très très bon j'adore j'adore la
fabrication tu sens qu'il ya un truc
artisanale ukraine forte neuf là c'est
comme un gant maison oranje sont des
vieux ses fruits je les flingues avec un
canasson fa oui ça prendrait des heures
alors je les pose les regarde style de
malades mais le et là ça tombe est super
bien j'ai dit ah quand on écoute moi les
bottes si tu veux j'en ai en fait bon il
dit c'est moi mais quelque part c'est
donc maintenant elles sont un peu usés
elle sent qu'il n'a pas fait ça chez soi
qui n'a pas posé allez une paire de
bottes un chat pour la regarder et se
mettre juste dans le bon angle faisant
état déchire merci beaucoup à tous et
merci merci tchika voilà